[Music]
because of this renewed aggression the
qatari role was again as it always is
through contacts made by the qatari
ministry of foreign affairs headed by
his excellency the minister of foreign
affairs and deputy prime minister with
the various parties with the palestinian
factions in gaza with the relevant
international parties and with the
israeli party with the aim to stop this
aggression and stop the continuous
bloodshed in fact qatar supports various
international efforts in the framework
of reaching the truce that took place
today
[Music]
as far as israel is concerned this
operation is over the objective was to
neutralize islamic jihad with most if
not all of the senior leadership being
killed as well as
the feeling that a kind of divide had
been created between islamic jihad and
hamas which governs gaza with hamas
remaining on the sidelines
people in gaza don't get to go back to
anything like normal because they're
still living under israel's siege that
is a form of silent violence against
every man woman and child in gaza 24
hours a day
365 days a year for 15 years
[Music]